Nigeria es un país famoso
por... ¡Su industria del cine!
¡Habéis oído bien! A estas alturas, todos
sabéis que India y Estados Unidos son los
dos países que producen más películas en
el mundo. Pues bien, Nigeria bien podría
estar en el tercer puesto. Sólo en 2022 han
producido más de 2500 películas. De hecho,
de igual forma que hablamos de Hollywood o
Bollywood, bien podríamos hablar de Nollywood.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando! ¿Cine
nigeriano? Ni siquiera sabía que eso existía.
Y tenéis razón. Hablamos de películas de muy bajo
presupuesto, que sólo se consumen en África. Pero
esto es un buen ejemplo de todo el potencial que
tiene este país... y lo poco que lo conocemos.
Nigeria no es un país africano más: es el país
con la mayor economía de toda África. Hablamos
de una potencia petrolera en toda regla, con
potencial de convertirse en una nueva Rusia.
Sin embargo, estoy seguro de que cuando
pensáis en Nigeria, la primera imagen
que os venga a la cabeza sea esta.
¡Exacto! El país de Boko Haram. El país
donde llegaron a secuestrar a 276 niñas en 2014.
Mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, la triste
realidad es que Nigeria, por mucho potencial
que tenga, es hoy por hoy un país miserable.
Por muchos ingresos que genere el petróleo, el
40% de la población vive en la pobreza absoluta.
Hablamos de más de 80 millones de personas. Porque
sí, Nigeria es el 7º país más poblado del mundo.
Tienen más de 206 millones de habitantes
¡Pero no sólo eso! Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver el enorme potencial de este país.
Es el noveno país del mundo que más ingresos
obtiene por la exportación de petróleo crudo. Y
en el ranking de países con más reservas se lleva
el puesto 11, justo detrás de Estados Unidos.
Y aquí viene la gran oportunidad de Nigeria:
la Unión Europea necesita
nuevos proveedores de petróleo,
y Nigeria podría ser uno de los más importantes.
Además, este país tiene una Constitución y una
estructura de Estado en teoría democráticas, algo
que la verdad no resulta nada común en África.
Aunque eso sí, lo que sí tiene en común con
otros países vecinos es la corrupción, la baja
participación electoral, las limitadas libertades
civiles y unas instituciones débiles que hacen que
la democracia nigeriana sea considerada muy débil.
Pero, a pesar de todo esto la pregunta es ¿De
verdad podría el petróleo y una mejora de
su democracia sacar a los nigerianos de la
pobreza? ¿Puede Nigeria salvar a Europa con su
zumo de dinosaurio? ¿Podría incluso convertirse
en una especie de Rusia africana... sin los
problemas de la Rusia original, claro está? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(UN PAÍS, 250 ETNIAS)
Nigeria es un país del que seguro que ya habías
oído hablar. Al fin y al cabo, es el séptimo
país más poblado del mundo y uno de los que más
petróleo tiene. Pero, ¿qué es Nigeria exactamente?
Veréis, Nigeria está habitada por aproximadamente
250 grupos étnicos. Cada uno con sus propias
tradiciones y lenguas. HAUSAS, IGBOS, YORUBAS y
cientos más se distribuyen por todo el territorio.
Pues bien, cuando llegaron a este lugar
los británicos y establecieron un
régimen colonial a mediados del siglo
XIX las asperezas entre los grupos étnicos
mayoritarios no tardaron en producirse.
De hecho, los británicos dividieron la
colonia en 3 regiones: el Norte de los
hausa y los fulani musulmanes, el Este igbo
y el Oeste yoruba, principalmente cristianos
¿Y creéis que las trató a las tres por igual?
Pues no, para nada, el ojito derecho del Imperio
en la colonia era el norte musulmán, donde los
emires ayudaban a las fuerzas británicas a cambio
de lujos. En fin, lo típico.. El caso es que
al final los británicos optaron por otorgar la
independencia a Nigeria en 1960, pero no porque
ya se cansaran de ellos, sino porque ya había
grupos activistas presionando demasiado.
Hablamos por ejemplo del Grupo de Acción o el
Consejo Nacional de Nigeria y los Camerunés.
Sin embargo, ya os imaginaréis que un país
creado a partir de 250 etnias va a tener
problemas. Difícilmente se van a terminar
entendiendo políticamente. Y, ¿Sabéis qué?
Eso es exactamente lo que pasó. Y lo cierto
es que tardó muy poco en suceder.
Seis años después de la independencia
se dio el primer golpe de Estado. Desde
entonces, Nigeria quedó sumida en el caos:
hasta seis golpes de Estado entre 1966 y 1999 y
tensiones constantes entre el norte islámico y
el sur cristiano. Pero no, no solo hubo golpes
de Estado, ¡también tuvieronuna guerra civil!
(En 1967, en la actual Togo, informaron del
asesinato de ciudadanos de la región Norte de
Nigeria en la región Este. Los ciudadanos
del Norte se volvieron tan furiosos que
empezaron a atacar y a masacrar a
los igbos que estaban en el Norte.
Como es lógico, muchos de estos igbos
regresaron a su región de origen, la del
Este. Y, en ese mismo año, el teniente coronel
OJUKWU declaró la independencia de la región,
convirtiéndola en la República de Biafra.
Pues bien, al principio parecía que Biafra
tendría éxito, al fin y al cabo, era la
región más rica en petróleo de Nigeria. Pero
su sueño independentista fue con el tiempo
convirtiéndose en una verdadera pesadilla.
Acabaron totalmente rodeados y aislados, lo
que provocó una hambruna que acabó con más
de 3.000 vidas al día en Biafra, entre ellas
las de 1.000 niños. Insistimos, cada día.)
(“El hambre es un arma de guerra, y
tenemos toda la intención de usarla
contra los rebeldes” - Alison Ayida,
Jefe de la delegación nigeriana en
los diálogos de paz de Niamey, julio de 1968)
Al final, Biafra se rindió y volvió a formar
parte de Nigeria. Pero como podéis imaginar los
igbos no se iban a olvidar nunca este conflicto.
Sin embargo, a pesar de todo ello, en 1999
la situación empezó a cambiar Después de la
muerte del dictador Abacha dio comienzo
la llamada Cuarta República en Nigeria.
Después de varias constituciones fallidas
y repúblicas dominadas por completo por el
ejército, la Cuarta República parecía traer nuevas
esperanzas. En ese mismo año se celebraron nuevas
elecciones y el hijo del exdictador OBASANJO
ganó. Y desde entonces en las sucesivas elecciones
solo ganaron los elegidos de Obasanjo, todos del
Partido Democrático Popular, el principal partido
conservador y económicamente liberal del país.
Eso sí, siempre entre acusaciones de fraude
electoral y violencia política.
Sin embargo, en 2015, Nigeria
decidió dar un golpe sobre la mesa. Atentos:
N1(Elecciones de Nigeria: Muhammadu Buhari
gana la presidencia. BBC)
Exacto, queridos amigos de
VisualPolitik, en 2015 el pueblo nigeriano
dio un volantazo a la izquierda y eligió
al socialdemócrata Muhammadu Buhari, del
partido de la oposición. Ahora bien ¿por
qué es esto una buena noticia? No, no es porque
nos guste este político ni nada por el estilo.
Sino que en este caso y por
primera vez en la historia,
Nigeria tuvo una transición
de poder pacífica. Es decir,
que parece que la democracia puede llegar a
funcionar en este país. Así que la pregunta
es ¿De verdad esto es una tendencia que se va
a consolidar? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(¿LA RUSIA DE ÁFRICA?)
Con los años, Nigeria se ha convertido
en el principal país exportador de
zumo de dinosaurio en África. De hecho,
entre 2015 y 2019 estaba produciendo más
de 2 millones de barriles de crudo al día.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Angola,
que es su principal competidor en África,
sólo exportó 1.4 millones de barriles al
día en 2019. Por eso podríamos estar hablando
de una auténtica Rusia africana. Nigeria ha
mantenido sus exportaciones a base de zumo de
dinosaurio desde 1977, cuando creó su empresa
estatal. Pero la realidad es que el petróleo
nigeriano empezó a explotarse mucho antes.
(En 1937, cuando Nigeria era aún colonia
británica, las empresas petrolíferas
británicas Shell y BP empezaron a explorar el
territorio en busca de petróleo. En 1953 dieron
con pequeñas cantidades que todavía no podían
comerciar. Sin embargo, en 1956 dieron con su
primera mina de oro negro viable comercialmente.
Estaba en la ciudad de Oloibiri, en el delta
del Niger: la zona más rica en petróleo
del país. Estas empresas sabían que sus
inversiones estaban totalmente aseguradas,
por lo que decidieron empezar también a
refinar el crudo que estaban extrayendo.
En 1965 construyeron la primera refinería.
Y a partir de ahí llegaron más empresas: las
americanas Chevron y Texaco o la Italiana Agip.)
Y ya se lo que estaréis pensando: vaya caramelito
para las empresas petrolíferas, ¿no? Sin ninguna
duda. Solemos estar acostumbrados a ver que
los recursos energéticos están en manos del
Estado del país exportador. Claro, estos son los
modelos de Rusia o Arabia Saudita, por ejemplo.
Pero en Nigeria es mucho más flexible.
Sí, es cierto: la Constitución actual da
al Estado nigeriano todo el control sobre
sus recursos naturales y energéticos. Pero
la realidad es que nunca les ha temblado
el pulso a la hora de vender más derechos
de explotación por cheques bien jugosos.
Por eso no nos extraña que Nigeria tenga 159
campos petrolíferos y 1.500 pozos de extracción.
Y, desde luego, muchos no son del Estado.
Gran parte pertenecen a empresas extranjeras.
De hecho, según el gestor nigeriano de inversiones
petroleras, el 98 por ciento de las reservas de
petróleo y activos operativos del sector están en
manos de seis petroleras privadas occidentales,
entre ellas la más relevante es Shell.
Y no solo eso, entre Shell, Exxon, Chevron,
Agip y Texaco poseen hasta 6 terminales de
exportación petrolífera, además de varios
oleoductos ¡Pero a pesar de esto no os
equivoquéis! El Gobierno Nigeriano no es tonto.
Nigeria no ha dejado que las empresas extranjeras
tengan el control de toda la cadena de producción.
Las refinerías pertenecen al estado ¿Recordáis la
refinería que empezaron a construir Shell y BP
en 1965? El Estado la compró en 1978. Y casi
todas las grandes refinerías son estatales.
El caso es que sin duda alguna el petróleo
se ha convertido en la mayor exportación del
país: supone ¡más del 70% de todas sus ventas
al exterior! Ahora bien, ¿qué significa
todo esto? Pues si seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo ya os imaginaréis por
dónde van los tiros: exacto, corrupción.
Nigeria está plagada de problemas en torno al
sector petrolífero. No os sorprenderá si os
digo que una de las mayores lacras de Nigeria
sea la corrupción. Y no cualquier corrupción,
sino la corrupción del sector petrolífero.
Y es que si el impacto de la corrupción en
Nigeria no fuera tan grande, ni te lo estaríamos
contando. Pero es que… ¡más del 20% del PIB del
país se va por el desagüe precisamente por
este motivo! Para que os hagáis una idea,
solo con lo que pierde el país por culpa de la
corrupción se podría pagar toda su deuda pública.
El problema es que tanto políticos como
empresarios se han beneficiado de la corrupción
en el sector. Por ejemplo, la exministra del
petróleo de Nigeria, Diezani Alison-Madueke,
fue condenada por permitir que desaparecieran nada
más y nada menos... que 20.000 millones de dólares
de la Empresa Petrolífera Nacional de Nigeria.
Incluso la persona más rica del país y de África,
Aliko Dangote, un empresario, ha sido acusado de
comprar favores al expresidente Obasanjo en 2003.
(La corrupción ha llevado a que los
ciudadanos nigerianos no vean muchas
veces ni un dólar por la venta del crudo de
su país. De hecho, según el Banco Mundial,
solamente un 1% de toda la población
de Nigeria se ha beneficiado del sector
petrolífero. Esto no sólo es una mala noticia
para los nigerianos: también lo es para las
propias empresas petroleras. En muchas partes de
Nigeria, las personas están empezando a vandalizar
los pozos y a robar el crudo y los combustibles
de las ya cochambrosas refinerías y oleoductos.)
Por lo tanto, no nos sorprende
encontrarnos con noticias como esta:
N2(Las refinerías petrolíferas ilegales de
Nigeria: Sucias, peligrosas, lucrativas. BBC)
En muchas ciudades y pueblos, como en los del
Delta del Níger, los ciudadanos se dedican a robar
crudo y vandalizar instalaciones petrolíferas.
Para muchos de ellos, esta es la única forma
de salir adelante en un país con una tasa de
desempleo del 33%, y del 54% para los jóvenes. Por
lo tanto, la corrupción ha llevado a que en
todo el sur del país, muchas comunidades se
dediquen a robar crudo y a refinarlo ellos mismos.
Pero si fuera este el único problema… Atentos:
T3(¿UN ESTADO FALLIDO?)
¿Recordáis Biafra, el territorio que se intentó
independizar en 1967 de Nigeria? Bien, pues cuando
os decíamos antes que los igbos no habían
olvidado lo que sucedió durante la guerra civil,
nos referíamos a que hoy muchos de ellos siguen
a pie de cañón. De hecho, los secesionistas
igbos tienen su propio grupo militante
Este grupo se encuentra hoy en la lista
negra de grupos terroristas para
Nigeria ¿Sabéis por qué? ¡Pues
porque el gobierno de Nigeria los acusa también de
robar el crudo y sabotear las refineríasY claro,
sea como sea, una cosa es cierta, los robos
de crudo en el país han hecho que el Estado
nigeriano pierda millones de dólares.
Para que os hagáis una idea, algunas
estimaciones señalan que desde el año 2008, las
pérdidas por los robos, lo sabotajes y la caída
de la producción resultante pueden alcanzar
los $100.000 millones de dólares. Vamos,
que es lógico que los dirigentes del país y los
inversores internacionales estén preocupados.
Pero no es el único grupo terrorista del país,
ni mucho menos. De hecho, tampoco es el más
sanguinario. A decir verdad, el más temido de
todos ha sido y es uno que muchos de vosotros,
estoy seguro, ya conocéis: Boko Haram.
(Boko Haram nació en 1995 como un grupo
juvenil musulmán no violento. Sin embargo,
con el paso de los años, al considerar que
la deriva de Nigeria era totalmente contraria
a los deseos de Alá, comenzó su cruzada para
convertir al país en un Estado islámico
regido por la Sharia. Y para lograrlo,
en 2002 empezaron a adoptar formas violentas.
Su primer objetivo fue la ciudad de MAIDUGURI,
y su expansión comenzó hacia el resto del país.
Especialmente, el Noreste de Nigeria. No obstante,
no fue hasta 2009 cuando comenzaron a
ganar la fuerza que les convirtió en
el grupo terrorista más temido del país... y
uno de los más sanguinarios de toda la región
del Sahel. Su narrativa apela a los sectores
más desfavorecidos del país. Así es como han
llegado a reclutar a más de 40.000 combatientes.)
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque Boko Haram no
es el único grupo terrorista que
asola Nigeria. Fijaos en este mapa:
Además de los problemas con Boko Haram
o el movimiento secesionista por Biafra,
el gobierno nigeriano tiene otros frentes
abiertos. Ya sea el de las bandas en el
noroeste del país, o el secesionismo Yoruba
en el sur, como el de Biafra, o el conflicto
entre pastores musulmanes y agricultores
cristianos que atraviesa todo el país.
Entonces, ¿es Nigeria un Estado fallido? La
mayoría de analistas no tienen duda: lo es. El
gobierno nigeriano no tiene el control de la zona
dominada por Boko Haram. Tampoco puede intervenir
en el conflicto entre pastores y agricultores. En
este caso, hablamos de un conflicto que ha acabado
con la vida de más de 20.000 personas desde 1999.
No obstante, hay otros que no se fijan tanto en el
control del Estado en todo su territorio soberano.
Por eso, también hemos escuchado a analistas que
prefieren decir que no es un estado fallido,
sino un estado que está fallando: que no es lo
mismo. Es más, estos dicen que Nigeria puede
empezar a funcionar por 3 razones: hay mayor
estabilidad política, hay mayor tolerancia entre
grupos étnicos, y hay una identidad nigeriana más
fuerte. Pero, la realidad es que, a día de hoy,
el Gobierno de Nigeria no puede controlar todo su
territorio. Dicho de otra forma: a día de hoy, es
un estado fallido. Sin embargo, las cosas pueden
cambiar. La guerra de Ucrania ha supuesto
una ventana de oportunidad para este país.
Y diréis ¿Qué tiene que ver lo que pasa en Ucrania
con... ¡¿Nigeria!? Pues... atentos a esta noticia.
N4 ( Rusia prohibirá la venta de petróleo
con topes de precio, según el Kremlin.
Moscú está dispuesto a reducir la producción para
compensar la pérdida de exportaciones, según el
viceprimer ministro Alexander Novak. POLITICO)
Rusia ya ha comunicado que no va a dar más
petróleo a la Unión Europea si le pone
un precio límite. Eso significa una cosa:
Europa necesita nuevos proveedores de zumo de
dinosaurio. Esta podría ser la oportunidad de
Nigeria de empezar a cambiar las cosas. Además, el
crudo nigeriano tiene una calidad muy similar al
de arabia saudita. Es decir, la mejor calidad,
fácil de refinar y relativamente barato de
extraer. Nigeria puede empezar a hacer que sus
pozos trabajen sin descanso. SIn embargo... hay
varios problemas que pueden romper este sueño.
El principal es que su producción
de barriles diarios depende de lo que diga la
OPEP+. Y teniendo en cuenta la tendencia que
llevan últimamente, van a seguir reduciendo su
producción para alzar más los precios. Además,
la inmensa corrupción en el país va a seguir
haciendo que este sueño sea imposible. Cuanto
más dinero se robe y menos llegue a los
ciudadanos, más robos y sabotajes tendrán:
en otras palabras: menos dinero. Es una especie
de círculo vicioso. Por último, las refinerías
y algunos oleoductos se encuentran en pésimas
condiciones. Los fondos del gobierno pasan por
tantísima burocracia que el mantenimiento de
las instalaciones petrolíferas muchas veces es
casi nulo. Y, claro, cuanto peor están las
infraestructuras, menor es la producción.
Nigeria ha dado el primer paso para solucionar
estos problemas consiguiendo cierta estabilidad
democrática. Pero habrá que ver lo que
sucede en las elecciones del próximo año,
porque sabiendo la historia de Nigeria, no nos
extrañaría que hubiera otro golpe de estado. Pero
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros: ¿conseguirá
Nigeria acabar con la corrupción y el terrorismo?
¿Llegará a convertirse en la nueva Rusia para la
Unión Europea? ¿Logrará mejorar las condiciones de
vida de sus ciudadanos? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.